there's nothing
[Music]
numbers
[Music]
August 17 2022
300 million American senses of humor
were silenced on the day YouTube
attacked the survivors of the comedic
cleansing called this homosexual War
cancel culture
they lived only to face A New
gender-neutral Nightmare the war against
Free Speech
the big Tech cabal who controlled the
media Outlets the New World Order sent
Bad actors and phonies through the news
channels their mission to destroy the
core of American Pride and the American
dream
our culture
the resistance was able to send a lone
Warrior a protector of pure comedy it
was just a question of who would reach
America first
come with me if you want to laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
man's barbecue this weekend he was
inebriated and he's a sweetheart
before I move on here that we have a lot
to get to sometimes you ask hey what can
you do to support the show and like Dave
you just came back and fans will like a
fan just gave me a check yes we can't
cash those I can if you want to just
change the name especially when it's uh
out to drug dealer Lou yeah
you know you should I mean it's almost a
little on the nose uh but the best thing
you can do look hit the like button
share leave comments below because it
helps with the YouTube algorithm and you
know what go out to a live show we still
have tickets in Houston it's it's one of
those areas where we can expand it from
you know like four or five six thousand
so we're able to see how many people in
Houston you can get out it's a lot of
fun to be around with thousands of
people and just a wall of uh laughter
fun it's a party it's not it's not a
think tank event
no no it's a lot of fun and remember
Colorado we was deafening yeah it was
awesome yeah it was incredible so that's
what you can do um it's gonna be packed
we don't do any patreons we don't have
any GoFundMe is there enough freeloaders
on this ship all right we're gonna be
talking about Kamala Harris she's a
fraud and then we'll be talking about uh
I don't know uh if you know this Visa
Mastercard Amex all these major credit
card companies now they're effectively
creating a gun registry so um
what do you do here's my question to you
what do you do I'm a recovering
libertarian comment below there you can
hear it to a man what do you do when you
have company when you have Facebook
Twitter Google YouTube Apple Amazon and
now you have all these major credit card
companies of course Banks who've decided
to work with the government does the
libertarian argument of ah the First
Amendment your rights only applies it
relates to government I I don't think so
anymore I don't think so we're at a
point where there's nowhere you can turn
without the influence and pressure not
only the national government but
International governments so talk about
that more they're also a donkey wieners
being smuggled that's something you want
to stay tuned for Gerald how are you I'm
doing well why did you lead in with
donkey wieners to me well you were so
enthusiastic about it run through that's
that's fair point yeah you brought your
own yeah I know one of those busts was
me I'm actually waiting sentencing and
then uh quickest man on his feet we are
live there I guess we just opened up 200
tickets in Phoenix yeah uh so you can go
to live withcutter.com tour September
16th Phoenix September 17th Houston the
rebels of the cause tour uh Dave Landau
Ahoy good how about you sir I'm fine can
I can I take a moment before we get to
the news to tell you the story and I
don't know if this is I don't know if
this is one of those things where when
you become a dad you find things funny
other people don't find funny oh for
sure but I would like some advice here
because not crib death no no SIDS is not
funny no hey this is ironically a kid
named Sid that's right and it's still
sad so I don't know what you do when
your child does something horrible that
you ABS but you involuntarily can't help
but laugh oh yeah my son did something
not that bad
you tell me if you think this is
actually something it's just because I'm
a dad that is funny so I have twins
right there's a girl and a boy and they
rough house a little bit right and
people ask if they're identical yeah
exactly and you want to hit them yes
exactly well these are leftist doctors
yes you didn't assign a gender did you
no I didn't no one does no one assigns a
gender okay
um so she grabs him by the collar this
weekend pulls them down just grabbing by
the collar and kind of pulls them down
and he's a really sweet boy my son so he
often like he'll give her things if she
wants them if she's crying he gives her
his pacifier so here's what happens he
falls down she laughs he gets up and he
looks at her and you go
and he takes out her pacifier that's not
the funny part so he takes it out and
she starts crying they're one year old
exactly and then he looks at her and I
swear to you this happened he starts
motioning putting the pacifier and she
opens her mouth like he's going to give
it back like okay and then he fakes her
out and smacks her with the pacifier
fake out like this and put his body into
it oh my gosh like a Stockton slap and
with the pacifier was it retribution for
something that's what it was because she
pulled him down he faked her out she
said uh I went and my dad another oh my
God like don't do that you know we say
no but it's just what do you do when
it's that funny
you laugh and say no he faked her out
yeah driving a lime green Cadillac once
yes
that's hilarious it's funny they're one
I mean it's hilarious I know it's wrong
to say it but it's funny it's funny I
mean the kids do horrible stuff that's
kind of funny yeah I think that's a big
part of it defines who you are people
say kids are so innocent and no no if
you understand the Human Condition kids
are awful horrible selfish beings if
left to their own selfish motivations
that's why you have to teach them right
from wrong and liberals believe that we
are all inherently good and of course as
people who are conservatives we
understand that there's damage that can
be done because people are inherently
bad so we want to mitigate that
centralized power I don't want the
president to fake me out with a passy
and smack me that's the point if they do
that to him all the time yes they do in
the old folks they have the silicone
spoon so it doesn't choke them
it is true though it's so Trey Parker
Matt snow were saying too and they
invented South Park and people like how
can you make kids look that awful and he
was like they are awful yes that's why
they're selfish and terrible level so we
do that with the kids are you better now
or when you were a teenager think about
it of course you grow you evolve unless
you're in this room this is like
Neverland it is
um
Captain Hook wasn't that bad okay just
for really quickly in case you thought
before we get to the news in case you
thought
if before this you thought as Nick
depalo says that soccer is for
six-year-olds and homosexuals from
Greece
you stand corrected
[Music]
this is in Sweden
and most of those are men are you
serious yes
[Applause]
[Music]
what the
those are men this is soccer
in Gold this is why I don't care about
sucker that watch the man right in the
middle in gold rate that pirouette
that's a man what
he was a man that's an athlete
in Europe that constitutes an athlete
ladies and gentlemen that's why we left
this is not real soccer Is that real
soccer no it's of course not what is
this is that's a pre-soccer thing isn't
it
what is this it's something in Stockholm
that is exactly how I picture a
Stockholm that's true syndrome yes
the Right One In A Vampire
movie a festival because of monkey pox
so they did that why would anyone attend
this just like well this is fun that's
great now we have several hours of the
game to watch it and it's the unskilled
gay dancing that's what's most offensive
there's nothing good about it it's not
even choreography no it's not not until
they scored a goal apparently then they
got in a circle and twirled that
cupcakes pure reading I don't know what
it's called the other one's doing the
splits like if Greg Louganis just belly
flopped in glitter well it's not scale I
guess not the AIDS thing it's that
you're not good yeah here comes their
dads to congratulate them nobody comes
up
uh moms how about Moms come down
congratulations
that's about all we have on that so uh
gross I don't know if you and this is it
starts off this is pretty silly but then
you understand why it's concerning hint
for [ __ ] spoiler China so uh September
8th uh I don't think oh I don't have
this thing
um there was a shipment of 7 000 donkey
penises and 16 sacks that were
intercepted by Nigerian Customs officers
toothbrushes
100 kilograms of donkey uh appendages
and if you're going to number that's the
poundage uh or kilograms we're going by
Metric here
2754. and you're wondering why these
penises are being used to make a
traditional medicine in China called uh
ujiao which purportedly treats or
prevents many problems including
miscarriage circulatory issues and
premature aging so there you go your
next great superpower oh not good
I just thought there was naked women to
be used as steaks at Golden Corral which
is now what is Hunter Biden going to
pass out on Halloween yes they were
march to stelter by the way that's he
just he uses them as cocktail swords
all right let's a lot of dogs so let's
move on here hey uh two minutes can you
get this thing uh going here because
yeah let me make sure I hit the plugs
I'm looking into it okay
um have you guys been reading about this
is one of those issues and I I want to
hear from from you because we've talked
about this with politicians with Marco
Rubio on last week yeah and Libertarians
I think it's a very lazy argument when
they'll say well the first amendment
only applies to the government it
doesn't apply to social media so we've
talked about that well hold on a second
if the government is telling social
media what they can and can't say or if
social media is subject to International
forces pressures coalitions uh and then
it affects you as an American at what
point are you no longer an autonomous
human being so we have five companies
that control 90 something percent of all
the information that flows uh and then
we also have now credit card companies
and this is a basically effectively the
first step towards a gun registry and
what happens is if you can't get it
through the legislation because it's
unconstitutional well they'll do it
through businesses who by the way get
bailed out and have kickbacks from
government so the two are one and the
same we really are at a point in this
country where it's hard to tell the
difference it's hard to tell the
difference between a private bank a
private institution in the United States
government so Visa Mastercard American
Express uh they're now going to be
tracking all gun purchases uh using a
new this purchase code that they've set
up and I'll get into why this is the
case but these are all major credit card
companies charge cards for people who
are Defenders of American Express
and of course the left loves it so who
lobbied for this is important but first
uh I just want you to understand I hear
it straight from the horse's mouth
credit card companies or certain Banks
or other Financial Services providers
wow who say to themselves you know what
this is not the business we want to be
in exactly it looks like a painting with
the eyes that follow you do that
came to life they can make that choice
and so we will and I'm sure there'll be
debates about that but the larger
opportunity here for everybody who has
children who cares about teachers and
Americans here and yes there may be a
hundred or a thousand people annually
who'll be lawful what uh citizens who
will be inconvenienced by an extra phone
call that they will have to take either
from a credit card company or the police
but I would argue to you
to you
inconvenience if it saves a life or it
saves 50. there it is is one of the most
worthy trades
can we do away with this argument if it
saves one life if it saves one life okay
well then you know what let's just
permanently quarantine urban areas
meaning they'll just strip them if
they're right what because you would
reduce crime
by significant degree that's where you
know inter gun uh related crime
especially that would help young black
men right they're disproportionately
killed by gun crime in inner cities you
can't do that why because it's a
violation of Rights but it would save
one life it would save one life the
inconvenience of being targeted by the
NSA FBI or intelligence communities as
proxy arms of well I guess these credit
card companies are proxy arms of our
American intelligence communities he
says police notice that little bait and
switch you're not going to be called by
the local police department you go and
you purchase or you do an FFL transfer
with your AMEX card and the next thing
you know you're being rated like it's
Mar-A-Lago
this is pretty stupid though because his
own argument doesn't work he says that
if you care about teachers if you care
about students that you're going to do
this obviously trying to pull on heart
strings for school shootings which is a
horrible thing this wouldn't prevent a
single one of them this would be used
after a shooting to see what happened
because somebody can walk in and buy a
gun it's not going to show up on MX it's
going to Ping that code that's it not
your purchase not what you bought I
could go in there and buy goggles I can
go in there and buy all kinds of
accessories for guns I can buy
ammunition I can buy whatever I want God
they won't well you know glass is still
so weird to start with this is goggles
you know whatever how many goggles
purchases are you making what are you
doing your free time and I get pinged
with a lot of phone calls just
confirming goggles right but that's not
going to prevent any of these shootings
baseless to begin with right right but
he's saying something that makes you
think oh well this is gonna if I care
about teachers yeah if you care about
teachers well I do care about teachers
if you care about kids why do you care
about kids then you're fine with uh your
private information being reported by
these uh these credit card companies to
the government who can then Target and
prosecute you by the way we've had this
in California just before we move on to
why this is happening in California
obviously you have even ammo for example
has to be uh it has to be tracked you
know who that affects most affects
competitive Shooters not mass Shooters
right it affects competitive Shooters it
affects Hunters it affects people who go
out and their hobby is working with
Firearms the truth is if you see most of
the time someone who has that many
firearms and that much ammo it doesn't
really necessarily mean that they're
prepper they're just people who are
meticulous about their firearms these
are the people who you want it's the
only area where we condemn someone if
they're in into Firearms we condemn them
as though it's worse worse with every
other hobby or with every other
profession or every other amateur
competitive sport we say hey it's great
the more time they spend with it the
more they fuss around with their
equipment the more practice they get but
with Firearms all this we want to say
that's a red flag so we want more
untrained people we want people who are
less familiar with their firearms this
is who these laws will
disproportionately affect first and then
they come for you now why is Visa
Mastercard Amex why I don't know about
Diner's Club
they're all about it yes this exists in
a vacuum no it doesn't exist in a vacuum
so the standard first was created by the
switzerland-based uh International
standards organization ISO that's what
we'll use for short in the future now
they set a lot of financial industry
rules now it's not a law
it's not a law right they suggested Visa
Mastercard American Express and then B
is a MasterCard American Express give
your private information over to the
government see how that works if it's
unconstitutional there are ways around
it and the new code was originally
proposed by The Amalgamated Bank of New
York
um and they brand themselves as a
socially responsible lender I'm sorry I
mispronounced [ __ ]
[Applause]
um and Congressional Democrats of course
uh they pressed credit card companies to
implement the new code so think about
this for a second they want to do away
with the filibuster they want to pack
the court right they want to do away
with these institutions that they blame
you for not trusting and when that
doesn't work when we have a Supreme
Court case for example that relates to
New York that it's unconstitutional for
them to not allow you to carry they find
workarounds in New York workarounds
where every single zone unless otherwise
expressed is a firearm free zone or they
send letters and I mean this quite
literally like socialist letters to
Santa Claus American Express Elizabeth
Warren wrote this she smoke signaled it
yes
she wrote a cookbook about it yes
how racist that is there's zero Native
American or she wrote The cookbook
powwow she got away with it because that
is so incredibly racist she had to think
about a stereotype how do Native how
would Native Americans write a cookbook
I'm gonna do that
so she wrote this to the credit card
companies to American Express Elizabeth
Warren we write to urge American Express
to support the creation of a new
Merchant category code MCC which is the
term you'll hear right now to sort of
whitewash it for gun and ammunition
retail outlets and to seek answers to
reports that the company has obstructed
efforts to create such a category which
would be an important step towards
ending Financial system support for gun
trafficking gun violence and domestic
domestic terrorism and let's be really
clear domestic terrorists we've never
heard that from the FBI from Ray
uh from multiple life it always is hard
for me to keep track of which officials
said but conservatives are the biggest
threat they're domestic terrorists well
the the with the inventive square at
least all the gang bangers can use
credit cards to purchase their illegal
guns yes that's what this assumes
because it's like oh we're gonna end gun
violence and we're gonna end gun
trafficking right right because
everything I've ever bought illegally is
with a credit card well you want the
points yes exactly it's like 10 times
points if you use it on an illegal
substance plus it's kind of a flex I
like to show them my Centurion card yeah
exactly you get 500 I get a lot of Sky
miles for fentanyl yes yes do you have a
white card I like a white sauce but see
yes this is what happens mix white when
you say slippery slope it's not an
intellectual fallacy if you're already
on that slope right Gun Show loophole
we've told you it's not really a
loophole as a matter of fact this is
something I have had to use the Gun Show
loophole why let me give you an example
Walther sometimes have to send me new
products to sample uh and sometimes I'll
get multiple products and then some one
time one was for you and so what I do is
I ship to me then I do a legal transfer
you know half asian creates a document
we draft it up where it's legally
binding and strength there's your Gun
Show loophole yeah you cannot find
crimes that have been committed and
certainly not to a statistical
significance of people getting their
guns through gun show loopholes I said
it's a Gun Show loophole let's close a
Gun Show loophole then they expand and
say it's the online loophole which
really isn't an online loophole just
means that you can purchase it illegally
and now they say well it's not a
loophole let's just track legal
purchases of firearms if we think I
don't know it's a little bit over the
limit and we want to draw suspicion
right Visa Mastercard Amex you have
international government pressures
Elizabeth Warren Congressional Democrats
and it's not even a law and now your
information is available to the federal
government do you see this game
this is why I'm a reform I'm a
recovering libertarian yeah
there is no line anymore between
corporations and government they are the
government by the way just to give an
example Amex received over 3.3 billion
dollars in bailouts oops
crap are you serious
get none of them none of them are immune
from these bailouts so what happens is
they get bailouts from the government
the government says you better play ball
they are effectively like the mob and
then the media blames you for not
trusting the institutions well why the
hell do you think that is
Airlines Banks health insurance
companies are these industries that
you're huge fan because they are the
ones who are the largest recipients of
bailouts and then of course they have to
play ball and you say well my freedoms
are just being removed more and more and
more bailouts then they get a letter
from Elizabeth Warren and it's not a law
but your information is now available to
them that's how it works you guys
weren't doing well enough if you're
putting people in crippling debt for the
rest of their lives yeah yeah no we need
more money sorry listen uh look
everybody the average is forty thousand
dollars in debt with our card we don't
know what to do well I don't even know
how that happens with Amex right it's a
charge card I don't think you're allowed
to carry over but maybe you are but it's
incredibly punitive yeah with uh Amex
yeah oh if you don't pay yeah it's
basically like a charge card not really
like a credit card but of course the New
York city mayor Eric Adams
remember we all had high hopes for this
guy yeah
he said he cheered the code and he said
when you purchase an airline ticket or
pay for your groceries your credit card
company has a special code for those
retailers it's just common sense that we
have the same policies in place for gun
and ammunition stores here's the
difference first off whenever someone
tries to compare Firearms to anything
car insurance let me try and compare it
to groceries when they try and compare
it to take your pick those aren't
expressly outlined as a constitutional
right yeah in the Bill of Rights in the
com it's it's amendment number two
that's why it is different you may not
like it but that's why it is
fundamentally different and there's a
huge difference between a code from one
of these companies
because they want to they want to
internally track what it is that you're
buying and that often sort of that data
determines what they create rewards for
going in the future a lot of the times
they have these like online marketplaces
right where you can use your points
versus a code that is being implemented
because of international governing
pressures Shadow governments and then
the United States government demanding
your private information which we have
seen them misuse time and time again
it's not the same thing the false
equivalency does it work for anyone
again best thing you can do
comment below hit a like hit a like if
you want people to learn this is one of
those things that you won't hear a lot
about because the Queen Another One
taken not too soon is rolling through in
a hearse with some palominos I don't
understand why they're burying her in
Scotland I thought they didn't like each
other what was odd was the guys in the
Kilts twerking on the hearse yes very
weird that was sort of disrespectful but
I guess she wanted it well we don't
understand their Traditions no so much
moisture from the ball Prince
it's a hot day they ran out of washer
fluid ventriloquist dummy guy at the
very beginning he glossed over this but
this is one point so this is not just
about tracking what you do this is about
credit card companies choosing not to
allow those transactions to take place
in the first place right they glossed
over that but they said it he said and
they can decide whether they want those
transactions to happen they didn't go
into any detail and it's like wait a
minute so you're telling me that they
could deny that code across the board no
American Express card holder if they
chose could make a purchase at that
store it would be declined
unless you got cash
I mean you could do it with cash basis
not a lot anymore we tend to use always
go get a cash advance from the same cart
really yes I mean there's a lot of ways
to go around this is why it's stupid on
so many levels but who does again what
is the goal here is to make
voters out of criminals of course and
law-abiding citizens into criminals it's
to make criminals into voters and you
into a criminal you go and you purchase
a firearm ah well you know what you
can't if you use any of the major credit
cards which you most likely do wait do
you want to go around it well I guess
what the next step is I bet you that
won't be allowed you don't think they're
going to crack down on cash purchases
they're going to funnel you into this
system that you have to use and this
isn't conspiratorial you can see it
happening before your eyes this is we
really are in some unprecedented
territory here this is happening so am I
the only one who thinks this is
happening so rapidly well it's it's
obvious now right we're seeing it's the
ends justify the means right they're
saying oh well we want to prevent school
shootings and that's just the thing that
they you know throw out there for
everybody and they say okay then we can
then do whatever it is necessary to
prevent it and we're like well yes of
course average American says yeah of
course I don't want my kid to die in a
school nobody does right so go ahead and
do this this is only this this happens
in every other industry and so this must
be okay this is what they've said well
just fast forward a few years one you've
seen that it hasn't stopped any
shootings at all all none of the laws
that they ever promote really would do
anything at all for that and two this
keeps you from being able to make
purchases it starts with guns that's the
obvious this is a proxy registry let's
be really clear if you use any major
credit card you are now a part of a
proxy gun registry any guns purchased
going forward and I'm sure they can
probably apply it retroactively this is
a gun registry which of course is
unconstitutional we oppose in this
country I'll get into exactly why we
oppose it hey by the way can someone
bring me a pen I broke this like an
idiot again I don't know how many pens I
break per week thank God we buy them buy
them in boxes at Sam's Club 12. so uh
you have Elizabeth Warren running a
letter you have Eric Adams New York
biggest city in the country now you have
California New York's Pension funds also
lobbying for the decision of those tiny
little things yeah those are huge
financial stakeholders so to give an
idea California is a 400 billion dollar
fund New York's a 240 billion dollar
fund think about that you've got 400
you've got 640 billion dollars you have
ISO right basically an international an
international body that's not a
governing body but sets the financial
standards and then thank you very much
Maximus let me give you this one and uh
then you have American government
officials who this isn't a law
but you know what hey we did give you
that bailout right and we're going to be
able to determine which stores are
allowed to stay open by the way which
stores will be punished which gun stores
you don't think they can pick winners
and losers there yeah be a shame if you
didn't get a bailout next time be a
shame if you didn't get a bailout but
this the government's been doing this
with the states too right if you want
Federal funding which is basically us
giving you your money back that we
collected from your citizens and taxes
then you will do these things right
they've threatened that the entire time
this is the same thing I would not be
surprised and I'm going to go on a limb
here and say that the bank
may have had some pressure externally
because the bank asked the iso to do
this yeah the bank in New York that says
that they are a socially responsible
lender why don't we learn from this [ __ ]
can someone bring up I think it's
Houston I don't know if it's but there I
think it's Bank of America said we are
now specifically going to be lending
money going to be providing mortgages to
areas of color and we are going to relax
the standards we are going remember the
subprime loan issue and people say well
hold on they're not being bundled it's
not coming from the government of course
it is they write letters they make phone
calls haven't we see wait what happens
when you give money
in a market that's clearly a bubble to
people who have no ability to pay it
back then afterwards the government
never accepts responsibility to say oh
is predatory lending how in the hell
does that make sense I'm going to I'm a
predator I'm going to lend money to
someone who I know can't pay me back
even though that's how I make my money
oh wait it's guaranteed by the
government
and right now we have this with a gun
registry and what have we seen this by
the way when people say well hold on gun
Industries in that bet well Australia
they had I think was 96 right yeah in
1996 they had that gun registry
it was a buyback Beto O'Rourke
kickflipper in Chief said he supported
abide back like Australia well it's a
mandatory buyback what does that mean it
means it's a ban yeah it's confiscation
yes and now they're really turning it up
they're saying people who have not
turned in their guns are going to face
criminal penalties this comes from the
guardian if you surrender it you can do
so without penalty the alternative is a
not this is overlay C6 the alternative
is a knock on your door from the police
and the potential for serious criminal
penalties including imprisonment well
that's not scary when you have a
government that also had quarantine
camps for people with covet well don't
worry you could either go to the
quarantine camp or go to the quarantine
camp and pay a five thousand dollar fine
plus a two thousand dollar ride I think
yes one of the paddy wagons that they
have over there so it's not mandatory
you just choose your path to the
quarantine campaign yes right going to
the camp is mandatory how you get there
is not completely up to you it can be
either very expensive right right or not
you're extremely painful yeah you can
give us your gun or the police will be
at your door hmm my teeth are soft we
would poison their soul
we have kangaroos and then of course we
have New Zealand
they box
uh they have a similar registry with
violators subject to five years in
prison good Lord now this is one of
those issues where people say well we're
not there yet we'll keep them again
historically
1920 uh Germany's very important to this
right exactly
every single horrible fascist which will
bring us to Kamala Harris afterwards
when they try and accuse people on the
right of fascists don't typically want
to allow people more freedom to purchase
firearms allow people to speak freely
regardless of how offensive and demand
that actually private entities like
credit card companies and social media
not track your personal whereabouts
that's typically not the kind of action
that you take from fascist even if they
tweet things that you don't like fascism
to give you an example 1928 Germany's
liberal the white Mar Republic they
enacted gun registration laws requiring
licensing for all weapons and then of
course and this is one thing the left
says I've said this before Hitler was of
course
a leftist
the Nazis were socialists and people go
oh that's just so have you seen they try
they try and Gaslight have you seen
conservatives of course it's in the name
nationalist Socialist Workers Party
and what did they said well he actually
didn't disarm people Adolf Hitler Hill
only yeah only the Jews well how did he
do it it started with a gun registry
then in 1933 Adolf Hitler sees his power
what happens he uses those exact records
to identify to disarm and of course
simultaneously publicly attack political
opponents the Jews by othering them
saying they're the ones carrying
diseases they're the ones who are you
know others like people who perhaps
aren't unvaccinated and you're out there
purchasing Firearms let's create a
registry let's see if we can other half
the country and then abuse the that's
what fascism is you can see the steps
and we are in the either in the
intermediary steps right now we
absolutely are there's no doubt about
that yeah absolutely and that's the most
famous example that we have to point
back at because it had the most dire
consequences not for Germany but for the
world and it wasn't just Jews Jews were
the the convenient economical scapegoat
is it sounding familiar right now our
economy that we have to people that
don't get vaccinated are part of the
reason that we can't open our economy
back up right do you remember hearing
stuff like that it was also black people
gypsy and anybody that was deemed
handicapped Enemy of the State
handicapped all of that right soccer
players people so we talk about six
million Jews being killed in the
Holocaust there were about six million
other people outside of that as well
that is that should be the most
frightening thing that people who want
guns confiscation that should be the
most frightening thing that you ever
hear in your life because it allows a
government to just run rough shot over
you no matter what and it doesn't matter
if you like it today it matters if you
like it under 10 years because think
about it the next person that comes to
power could be against you right and
could hate the fact that you own an
electric vehicle
and come after you for that that's now
the dividing line all right these people
suck because it's all coal-powered it's
all these rare earth metals that we
can't we can't possibly you know get
enough of those to change what we're
getting rid of you guys it changes you
don't want this ever you want the
citizens to have guns to put down any
government that is tyrannical whether it
is right or left well and people say
you're just going to the Hitler
comparison which is like no I'm giving
you a historical precedent right that
exists a precedence in this case I think
both of them probably are appropriate so
you see that that's the worst that you
can imagine obvious that's the worst
case scenario and you see that with
dictator for dictator after dictator uh
but then you have the intermediate steps
we have people who are arrested people
who are going to be reported you see
what's happened with the gun buyback
it's mandatory in Australia and New
Zealand that's the between step and we
are right now going into that between
step well what's the best case scenario
where it's worked
Australia well look good point we'll
find some example that's the worst is
Hitler and the best is Australia now oh
good super yeah we're on the right track
oh Grace Aces oh well I mean Canada's
best best case example a guy killed 22
people on 16 separate occasions over the
course of days because nobody could stop
him and just had a mass stabbing of ten
yeah people don't hey he's got a pocket
knife I don't know what to do oh you
know we didn't screen there for the
Swiss army knife at first I thought he
was attacking people with the magnifying
glass there got a bottle opener to three
cats turned out he opened his skull
oh so uh by the way even if the guns
aren't confiscated if they're not
confiscated they're still going to be
tracked and logged again that's the
first step and keep in mind the FBI this
isn't an extreme yeah we know they've
used credit card info to track down
people January 6th sorry 911 times two
the sequel 911 more 9 11 or but to stop
to stop school shootings what would the
border patrol agent use to borrow and
then go into the school and stop the
shooting if these aren't allowed there
are two con there's one 100 constant
with mass shootings yeah the shooter is
invariably without exception stopped by
a good guy with a gun now that good guy
with a gun may be someone who's off duty
who has their own private firearm or it
may be the police although we've been
saying that's more and after sometimes
you know in a happy ending the feel-good
story of the year the shooter takes out
himself with a gun where he goes from
bad guy to good guy in that last flash
of a second the point is they are only
stopped by somebody with a Gun there's
no way around that number two it's not a
hundred percent but it's 90 something
percent depending on the stats all
references available at
loudtroncrediter.com these mass
shootings the current gun free zones
there you go we don't need to get down
to and sure maybe these also are
contributing factors psychotropic drugs
that are prescribed inappropriately
perhaps that's a chicken in the egg
thing maybe they were prescribed these
psychotropic drugs because they were
already mentally unstable perhaps you
can get to inter-race Crime related
statistics if our intelligence Community
would monitor them they actually won't
record these anymore maybe but 100 of
the shooters are stuck by a good guy
with a gun into the tune of 92 94 have
heard it as high as 97 percent of mass
shootings occur in gun free zones there
you go if any other problem existed
where you said okay hold on a second
what are the three lines 100 and 94.
let's start with that instead you have
Visa Mastercard and Amex telling which
gun telling gun shops that they can or
can't sell to you and tracking it and
sending it to the government by the way
Rolling Stone not a fan of them they've
also showed us that the FBI routinely
Harvest data from Facebook WhatsApp
iMessage
the FBI this the government constantly
tracks your whereabouts and uses private
information that you think is private
you probably don't sign those you
probably don't read those agreements no
any of you read the actual iTunes
agreements that you sign when they do an
update
give your lawyer scan it over
decent changes back to negotiate
yes it's not how it happens
no and and what's the problem with this
too as well is not only gun purchases
but then that becomes a macro issue if
the government can determine hey who's a
good citizen who's a bad citizen no
longer did they break the law but is
this someone who we believe is
good we believe is loyal we believe is
someone who potentially you know is not
a threat to the government that's right
end up with a social credit system like
I don't know exactly in China in areas
where the system is in full
implementation more than 27 million
airplane tickets as well as 6 million
High-Speed Rail tickets have been denied
because of low social credit scores
meaning that these people could not book
a plane ticket or a train ticket because
they had done something the government
found unsavory not something that threw
them in jail or was considered a crime
but something that was socially
unacceptable to the Chinese government
like owning a Bible and I by the way can
you bring up that picture what I love is
uh in that uh video gujju is just as
angry as bad Zoo yes
Matthew has a low credit score yeah oh
no 435 and good juice like oh no one two
seven eight
they're both angry none of them are
happy why is why even show good zoo I
have no idea just doesn't have the
travel money right exactly right no no
no that's he does he just can't travel
yeah he has a social score but he spent
all his money trying to build up his
good social score they duct tape
airplanes together over there Dave it's
not an issue Finance let's just get a
fake ID yeah well there you go yeah
that'll help too yeah why not they want
to turn you into a criminal law-abiding
citizens into criminals criminals to
ride a train millions of people like
you're not nice enough to ride a train
right can you imagine that oh I can't
ride in a giant cart of moth balls and
bum piss yeah guess what you're not
getting jammed into a Subway with a
broomstick today friend
millions of people turn down just all
you're doing is purchasing a plane
ticket or a train ticket you're turned
down because your social media posts
weren't glowing enough of dear leader
maybe you posted a Winnie the Pooh meme
you know right and now you can't travel
well I I I've received I think three
notifications this weekend from Twitter
that I was in violation of German law
good and this is what happens is not
only are you no longer subject to only
American law and federal law and
unconscious with unconstitutional
parameters International governments
they put pressure you think you think if
they're putting pressure on Fast and the
Furious 11 to change Flags in the
background you don't think that they're
pressuring the biggest the biggest tech
companies in the world who control 90 of
information of course they are and of
course our government is also behold and
think it's it's it's a tapestry that has
been weaved right before your very eyes
and I am tired of libertarian to say
well it's not the government no no it is
the government we need to get their
tentacles out and I I don't know how we
hit this reset button I'm very open to
suggestions comment below what you think
we need to do at this point and hit the
like button helps with the algorithm the
best thing you can do it's a live show
yeah Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern too that's where you can watch
it here you can watch it on Rumble you
can subscribe on audio we also have Mud
Club of course where we'll be doing
another hour today yes and to prove
we're live we actually have the funeral
of the queen playing on CNN right now oh
wow this just seems like a Minefield I
don't necessarily want to wade into hey
you want to become Network news real
quick we'll just leave that on and don't
say anything for 20 minutes
I'm sure Don Lemon chimes in here and
there no they don't they're just sitting
there going oh this is really important
this is World News why is there the
unwritten rule that you that you're only
allowed to wear bundt cake hats at
funerals well it just seems like it's
one of those things where you never see
these silly hats anywhere outside of
funerals with old ladies and it's just
as stupid looking there well it's a
funeral hat is that what it is well
that's where I wear is that what you buy
them at funeral hats Warehouse yeah I go
to funeral hats or us you're gonna like
the way you mourn this is yeah this is
what William Wallace died for right here
so yeah you can come back and bury the
royalty in Scotland great how does that
make sense
there's probably a really legitimate
reason I'm being sarcastic Scott I don't
want anybody back checking me I don't
got lanyards the police yes
are they burying her in a Scotland Yard
Stomp the Yard and that's what Channing
Tatum comes up and that's his ass on the
casket right okay I just wanted to make
sure he was going to do this he's a
white guy who kind of dances like a
black guy and you don't really like him
but they learn to respect him that's
that stomped the yard that's next but
who gets served I have no idea who do
they could surf a bunch kick out of a
hat oh Lord
somebody forgot to tell him to do his
hair this guy yeah no he did it he used
a balloon that's the best guy you could
get and he got CNN glasses I love it he
just came from the confessional Booth
with an altar boy yeah he sure no it did
I don't know wait two of them it's the
Episcopal Church I guess they don't do
confessional Booth I'm sorry no lost
true look he was just watching two
lesbian reverence yes his name was most
Reverend strange I don't Queen Is Dead
that's sad it's always sad when somebody
dies but it is she's 96. she's 96. yeah
how's that sad I don't understand like I
you die
no
run away from your feelings yeah my nana
died at 95 and wanted to be dead for a
long time like look she had a good life
this woman was a queen and died at 96.
that should be something to be
celebrated not so much mourned I just
don't understand the no and honestly
that's a real guy at 96 that's a
celebration of life that's not a like oh
what happened right no it's not like
they're surprised that she died no more
like that was more of a shock well
that's true well that was more of a plan
yeah right exactly that just wasn't
perpetrated
it was this queen and a pair of scissors
with the seat belts yeah yeah exactly so
interesting said if you're 75 or younger
you've never known another queen or King
in England no buckles limo rental
they went to anti-armoredvehicles.com
[Laughter]
let's be honest
foul play a little bit you think
yeah a tiny tiny bit but you know I
don't fully under I know I'm just
speculating but why would they have
reason to be jealous of the only person
who doesn't look inbred no it's it's
true they were like what what is this
thing and it's not like she was that
beautiful you know it's just like it
just looked like Wayne Gretzky in a wig
but compared to the royal family she was
stunning well standing next to them it
was just like what is that is it a
person exactly well she would miss out
on you know all of this this is a
procession of of uh I mean it's a
Cavalcade of Jim Henson characters yes
look at this and we're supposed to not
acknowledge it yeah this guy's just
wearing a a man pleasing bib yes
what is it a Crab Shack those are a bit
of the clergy what are you talking about
oh yes I'm sorry they're men of the
cloth
I apologize
admonish them show some respect to those
who were so inbred and promiscuous they
put on wishes
Freddie's New Nightmare no don't look
underneath
that's what it was just so people know
that the wigs it was syphilis syphilis
head yeah yeah that's why they had you
could see the brains my point is this
the royalty when do we say look now they
don't even really have any power and we
have to act like it really matters
Freddie Mercury was a great Queen and he
only lived to be what like 38 or
something something like that lots of
hits also uh I saw uh Chiron when Elton
John was playing and it said like you
know mourning the queen and he was on
screen and it just said the queen and I
laughed for about an hour so it's a chat
playing yeah he was playing something
was he doing Diana song yeah exactly the
one where he brought it back that's what
he's going to bring back his Candle in
the Wind and he is oh you know he's
mailing it in oh yeah yeah he's just
Candle in the Wind oh I gotta do this
again 96 year olds never will okay oh
Queenie this is just laziness I think
the king fell asleep oh boy you know
it's gonna be a long long time
for this funeral Muhammad vehicle
alignment as I said like are you just
making this up as you go right now Elton
John you know you're a Rocket Queen
you're a Rocket Queen no you're not
you're not going updates
the casket going around the Moon yeah
he's smoking doing like the Shatner one
you're a butt rocket Queen all right so
let's move on here to Kamala Harris okay
I was trying to put this off because I
hate talking about her is it possible
that she's getting whiter whiter yeah I
think they've been uh have you seen her
lately like it is weird she's it's like
it's like she's like a biracial werewolf
I've noticed she started straightening
wearing one glove yes oh really walking
backwards more than usual yeah
well that's because there's a mayor back
there yeah
uh comment if it's just me
it seems like she's
getting whiter there's always a mayor
back there
so
to have her hair caught fire the other
day it's the Kamala Harris Pete yeah on
September 11th uh obviously this
happened while we were on break but of
course in other words we were all
remembering what happened there I
remember exactly where I was on
September 11th I was in a school and I
remember that we had actually we had um
it was a centennial Regional High School
and we had some Muslim kids who laughed
were you sober at that point no no I was
uh I I honestly and by the way a lot of
loved all the firefighters out there
seriously I think what you guys do is
greatly appreciated um no I I woke up
and I don't know Tick Tock nurses but
I'll give them credit no but I went
thank you for twerking out all the fires
um I I honestly woke up and I walked
downstairs and I was hungover as per
usual and I was like wow what a terrible
pilot and my mom's like what is wrong
with you that's what I thought too but I
honestly thought it was a terrible part
I didn't I had no idea that that could
happen on American soil yeah then when
the second one happened I was going oh
yeah it was like what are the chances of
two terrible Pilots I'm not even kidding
and honestly the chances aren't that low
because they were still drinking yeah it
was pretty common yeah and uh but no I
remember it just being the craziest day
ever and I guess the most it affected me
I was like because they just kept
gouging gas prices I was like well gas
is like six bucks this is a real
terrible day for me well like you didn't
grasp it right because it's it it just
didn't make any sense right we had never
been under attack America was never a
place you thought would be attacked like
it was insane the whole day and here's
what's scary grasp it as you have a
generation right and we're I'm a
millennial but just below us younger
Millennials and and generations they
grew up without really remembering or
experiencing this right and that really
is formative yeah just the next day I
remember that American Americans
actually being proud Rudy Giuliani they
called off the dogs and all the racist
attacks because he cleaned up New York
right and of course I have some problems
with stopping Frisk but he had the
broken windows here we clean up the
Subways he changed that City everyone he
went to America's mayor George W bush
had the highest approval ratings of any
president after 9 11. I believe in
modern American history and how quickly
we forget so anyways September 11th
happened this weekend Kamala Harris
decided to uh take advantage uh and
compared the threat
of 9 11 and just to be clear if some of
these answers don't really make sense
we all feel the same way when we watch
this yeah uh because she compared 911 to
the present domestic threat which she
doesn't really accurately fully describe
but she's getting whiter let me start
with look we're at the 21st shave it off
chuck if you will of the September of
the attacks yeah this was like an
anniversary
attacking our democracy attacking this
country
we're now as a nation battling a threat
from within is the threat
equal or greater than what we faced
after 9 11.
that's an interesting question
um I have held many elected offices as
district attorney also a lot of balls
now Vice President and there's an oath
that we always take more so coupled
which is to defend and uphold our
constitution against all
[ __ ] and you know it
and
um we don't compare the two and the O's
but we know they both can exist and we
must defend against it
what huh the answer here's the thing
you're both terrible yes you're both the
answer is this
no
it's one of the stupidest questions I've
ever heard in my life Chuck and by the
way you're at that point I know you
think going shorter makes it you look
like a Chia Pet shave it off
hey Chuck go go over there and see what
one you like more yeah if you like it
here in America with what you consider
domestic terrorist or if you do better
with the Taliban right you know what
better yet just go over there go over
there go jump in that vat of acid we
have over there it's we brought it in
just for you it's in the Green Room yeah
so she continues by going on to say and
this is the important part too is is she
then goes on after this to talk about
fascism we just talked about the credit
card company yeah we just talked about
the laws that are being true posed of
course by the left true fascism when you
have letters written by government
officials before we get to that she went
on to compare again America uh uh to the
or the terrorism 911 in January 6th uh
it's complete here's what happens when
you have someone who's not smart who's
attempting to be a pseudo-intellectual
and I have problems with
pseudo-intellectuals to begin with but
she's not even good at that
so something about January 6th and Trump
supporters in America is being made
weaker this is one of the worst
interviews of a sitting uh president
that I've ever seen
when I think about what we have been
seeing in terms of the attacks from
within
I wish uterus attacks that we would
approach it the same way you're a big
fat boss As Americans
um instead of through some partisan lens
you know I was obviously you think this
threat is as great I think it is is
great and I think it is very dangerous
and I think it is very harmful and it
makes us
weaker
hold on a second before we go on just
remember this is late saying it's weaker
talking about January 6th where no one
died aside from one person trying to
enter the capital but this is the same
broad who on Colbert said that the
rioters not the protesters was actually
asked about the violence said they won't
stop and they shouldn't stop same person
everyone beware because they're not
going to stop it is gonna they're not
gonna stop before election day in
November and they're not going to stop
after election day and that should be
everyone should take note of that on
both levels that this isn't they're not
going to let up and they should not and
we should not
she's always wearing the only pearl
necklace that hasn't helped her Advance
her career
exactly
I like to wear the one that's not
dripping
who gave it to you Mary Willie Brown oh
this oh this I don't know it's this old
thing oh this Montel Williams
gave it to me with a juicer ew
no oh she's the one oh she's okay so
let's walk through some of her claims
here and you can feel free to hop in
wherever you want Joe some of her claims
here's a claim uh the first claim she
makes a claim that 9 11 and January 6th
are in some way comparable uh okay
here's the truth uh almost 3 000 people
29 90-something people died on September
11th and then of course we can look at
the numbers of the ensuing Wars in Iraq
over 4 500 dead 32 000 wounded in
Afghanistan 2300 dead 20 000 wounded
um here's another truth
no one died no one was killed on January
16th aside from what January 6th you
said 16th January 6th sorry September
11th January 6th yeah uh aside from one
lady who was shot by the police now
remember this is something that everyone
else was talking about when they started
with the news they were saying five
people died right that was a five people
died on January 6th remember they said
one was killed with a fire extinguisher
yeah yeah five people died five people
died five people died five people died
five people died nope
outside of one lady who was shot by
Capitol Police let me just walk you
through the five people who died it was
all natural causes number one Kevin
Greece and heart attack number two
Rosanne Boylan drug overdose number
three Benjamin Phillips stroke and then
of course officer sicknick this is the
one who they said was attacked with a
fire extinguisher was uh it was proven
that he died of natural causes only
number five Ashley Babbitt she was the
one who was shot by the Capitol Police
so how do you compare a targeting of
civilians from a foreign terrorist
threat
to an incident where you had hundreds of
thousands of Americans by the way the
capital who were completely non-violent
to an incident where only one person was
shot and it was shot by members of the
government
I I I don't know I think this is where
when people talk about common ground I
think we're so far beyond the pale I
don't know where I'm going to find
Common Ground I agree people shouldn't
have run into the capital of people who
weren't welcomed in I agree some people
were of course disruptive and I think
that they should be charged with things
like trespassing or if there was assault
but to compare to 911 no and is this the
greatest threat to our democracy that
we've ever experienced like to make that
claim the the reason that I keep coming
back to that every single time that it
happens because Chuck Todd set it up by
saying you know this threat that we're
fake that we're facing right now to our
democracy the threat that she said that
we're facing to our democracy right now
the only reason I bring that back is
because that is the justification for
extreme actions right every single time
it's the justification that they use we
have to go after Donald Trump because
he's lying we have to kick him off of
social media because he's now a threat
to our democracy we have to suspend the
rights of citizens because it's a threat
it's the same thing that we saw with
covet we have to suspend the rights of
people who can't and won't get
vaccinated because they're a threat to
the health of everybody else right it
justifies extreme actions and you can't
let them get away with it every time it
was not the greatest threat to our
democracy that we've ever had right now
what we're seeing from the Democratic
party going around Congress when they
can't get legislation through that they
like
going around Congress leaning on social
media companies leaning on these credit
card companies that is a threat to
democracy because that's when your
rights cease to exist yep not one not
one Assad says hey we didn't believe
what happened right and that brings me
to my next Point here of course she goes
on to then claim and a lot of these
people have Biden to have as well their
claim that Republicans are semi-fascist
is a term that they use
um here's one thing that I will say for
a lot of the the uh attacks or even
criticisms that are legitimate of Donald
Trump I love the fact that during covid
he was getting into fights with members
of the CDC I love the fact that there
are members of government who didn't
like the president I love gridlock you
know why because fascism can't breed in
that kind of an ecosystem it's not
possible it cannot replicate when you
have people who don't like each other
who aren't getting along who aren't
necessarily following lockstep that's a
good thing think about how concerning it
is when a party achieves power Democrats
and they write letters like you said
these private companies to create a gun
registry they want to pack the court if
they don't if they don't get the
decisions that they like and then they
want you to be removed from the Town
Square if you question election
integrity
what's really important to note the
difference between people who are in
power and people who aren't when people
are in power and the only decisions they
make are to accrue more power and to
silence dissent again Donald Trump my
complaints didn't do a whole lot with
social media he talked a big game but he
wanted everyone to be allowed on the
platforms
have you heard on mass Republicans a
semi-fascists calling for liberals to be
removed from misinformation
no look I don't even think anyone's
going to argue it
have you have you heard Republicans
calling for people conservatives to be
removed because they say hey you know
what maybe we need to strengthen our
election integrity and have voter ID no
it doesn't even exist
I don't know who's buying this it really
is weird but this is where we have this
Chasm so August 25th Biden called
Republican semi-fascists of course he
said it's not just Trump
it's not a joke it's the entire
philosophy that underpins it's almost
like semi-fascism and of course um
president Kamala Harris agreed with
Chuck Todd to Meet the Press what is a
semi-fascist
listen I think that um when we let's not
get caught up in in words
politicizing the fact that
most people in America now
that it is not helpful to our country
when we have people who are denying
elections or trying to obstruct the
outcome of an election where the largest
number of people in our country voted
for the president of the United States
and
um when we look at where we are I think
that we have to admit that there are
um attacks from within to your first
question
and we need to take it seriously and and
we need to stand up together all of us
and and think of this not through
partisan lens but as Americans there are
moments in time when we have to also
agree all good people who care about our
country
that there are those right now are
vividly
not defending right our democracy
and
I think we want that our
commander-in-chief that the president
United States will speak up and raise
the alarm about what this means to our
strength
huh it makes no sense but the
undercurrent is terrifying at least
she's not the leader of the Free World
well right at least for the amount of
facelift she's had she doesn't have
wrinkles all over her neck well she
still does oh yeah you're right I said
that with a little bile
I don't like her yeah I can't stand her
she's really she's really tough to watch
I know she's tough to watch and she is
she is the definition she was last place
she's job insurance for Biden let's be
honest she called the president racist
and then she was like oh by the way this
is my VP this is my VP we're all
supposed to go but didn't she all right
yeah whatever that's fine wasn't she
dead last
so here's another truth there's only one
party looking to regulate the ability to
defend oneself the first we're talking
about the Second Amendment then of
course we go to the First Amendment
censor speech from political opposition
as she just said she just said hey if
you question election Integrity you're a
threat to democracy uh there's only one
party that wants to weaponize a federal
government against opposition like FBI
raids like handing over credit card
information if you happen to have
purchased too many handguns it's not
even close I don't know who's buying the
[ __ ] at this point but there's a
good portion of this country that is
you're not going to find common ground
with them there are people with whom you
can find common ground but if people
believe that people believe that limited
government conservatives are the
semi-fascists then there is no pleasing
you here's another Truth for you don't
let this tin can we're about to hit you
in the teeth
um
there's also only one party that wants
to what of course pack the court
and they want to Nuke the filibuster for
abortion and things like voting rights
and what they mean by that is not have
to present ID so if you say hey hold on
a second we need election Integrity they
label you a fascist
simply for wanting people to present
identification to vote while these
actual fascists will change the
fundamental institutions of government
in order to be able
to Ram through things like no voter ID
things like packing the Supreme Court
doing away with the filibuster here she
is describing it in her own cackles
our president has said
he will not let the filibuster get in
the way
if the Senate through a majority vote
votes to pass the Women's Health
protection act he will sign it into law
you know what that means in the midterms
we need to hold on to the Senate and get
two more
and then we can put into law the
protection she holds up two for way too
long with her fingers but the millions
of women and people in America who care
about them to understand the
significance of protecting a woman's
right to make decisions about her own
body
telling her what to do 52 Senate seats
or more legislative filibuster gone or
just on this issue the president has
been clear on this issue he's not a very
important issue in addition to that
important issue which is voting right
it's pretty much a fog she loves
counting with her fingers it does two
one two
three like what do you what do you do
the Hang Loose sign this is what I do I
do the signs I do the signs with my
fingers the commander and she she can't
even get out without a laugh I love that
she can get up to two and then it's like
three yeah I don't I don't yeah she's
short circuits you know the signs
so you poured water on her batteries
two
I hope they play this on a loop in every
swing state senate race whatever it may
be because this is what's waiting for
you right now we don't like the results
that we're getting so we're going to end
the filibuster yeah the filibuster by
the way that we have video of Democrats
supporting including you know more
former vice president himself Joe Biden
saying that it's an institution right we
can't get rid of this right this is how
you protect the country from losing its
way is to not just let everything kind
of go through and by the way you start
making promises to Joe manchin and not
fulfilling those promises to get his
vote to swing legislation
which is what just happened
that's also bad for democracy that's not
how you're supposed to do business your
idea should be good enough to stand on
their own and they're not can we really
think of you know outside of questioning
the election did Donald Trump when he
was in powertrain do away with any
institutions did he try and change the
number of seats to the courts did he try
and did he encourage doing away with the
filibuster I mean people may not have
liked his appointments but they were
well within the realm of of
constitutionality and certainly the
Precedence that we have available to us
I just I can't even think of something
comparable and they were confirmed too
which is weird right hmm can we just
read that that interview is the second
worst 9 11.
well there was another one top three top
three yeah I think we can say top three
top three for sure she's like she's like
the Halloween three of Vice Presidents
gotcha she has no home right and you
don't think like is this the same I
guess she's there same thing I don't
count her but it's not good no
Halloween three is kind of good she's
not good she's the kind of broader when
people play duck duck goose they didn't
count her right there's like Duck and
they moved on down the trail and she is
in charge of your life the problem is
right now this there are a handful of
people again my litmus test for
conspiracies and I'll leave you with
this the Limitless test for conspiracies
is how many people have to be involved
Area 51 of you don't think that someone
who's working there a day worker you
know independent contractor is going to
blab so it's pretty tough to buy into
these but when you're talking about a
handful of Elizabeth Warren Eric Adams
like Joe Biden Kamala Harris they send a
letter out to credit card companies and
Visa Mastercard American Express say
aye aye Captain we'll make sure to
create a gun registry sorry not a gun
registry we'll create a code when you
have just a handful of people who say
you know what we're going to do away
with the legislative branch let's just
let's do away with the filibuster let's
let's also by the way we have executive
you watch Schoolhouse Rock right you
have executive you have judicial we have
the legislative well you know what let's
just make it all executive let's do away
with the legislative let's get rid of
the filibuster and some of these some of
these guard rails that we have you know
what let's do away with the judicial
which is supposed to be the most
autonomous let's pack the court as this
current president sees fit so you know
it's just it's just all executive it's
all and what do you end up with
you end up with a king you end up with a
dictator you end up with
fascism
and this is what the left does they
project and they accuse you of doing
exactly what it is that they are doing
they accuse you of being a fascist for
not wanting your gun purchases being
reported to the government for not
wanting people to be de-platformed even
people that you disagree with for not
wanting huge bailouts to companies who
then turn back into the government's
bidding
for not wanting to change the you're
blamed for not trusting the institution
of the Supreme Court because you want to
keep it as is and they want to pack it
whose fault is it that we don't trust
any of these institutions because I will
tell you what and we'll have Alex Jones
on this Wednesday as an Ash Wednesday
we'll see what happens there good luck
get me fitted for my tin foil hat
because I'm at the point where I'm going
there and just a few people running this
game and they are running it into the
ground we're going to go to mug Club
Here YouTube thank you very much but not
really and uh by the way if you're
watching hit the like button hit the
share button that helps with the
algorithm and we're going to do another
45 minutes to an hour here on mug club
with the what is it The Little Mermaid
trailer Little Mermaid oh my God this is
a bad day YouTube piss off
thank you